here with reaction Fox News contributor
former house Speaker Newt Gingrich you
know I look at the the seriousness of
this and I watched this guy and I can't
even comprehend how people cannot see
that he is not fit for this job never
mind everything that he said how
embarrassing he's been you know the oh
oh some hot ground man hot ground here
man and oh I almost lost my 67 Corvette
I can really relate to what happened and
Maui really Mr Speaker seriously
look I I think
this visit to Maui frankly is just plain
frightening uh how can you have a
commander-in-chief who is totally out of
touch with reality who makes up a story
which is a lie who has no understanding
of the scale of the disaster which has
occurred who has uh literally now has no
empathy for the human beings around him
and I think and of course as you point
out can't even stay awake now I think
that people need to look at this not as
a political problem but as a national
problem we have a commander-in-chief it
makes you wonder who's making the
decisions in the White House I
personally have a hunch it's Barack
Obama and you have to wonder
how is the system running in a real
crisis how could Joe Biden decide
anything it would all be delegated and
frankly as an American I'm ashamed
Clifton I've been to Lahaina many times
it's a wonderful town it's a great
historic place we love Maui and we love
that part of the coast and to see it
destroyed like this to realize that
almost like Pompeii and in Italy you
have families entire families who were
burned to death who were found now I saw
one report that firefighters are having
a very hard time psychologically going
from house to house because the scenes
of little children the scenes of
families who had gathered in the bathtub
in the shower trying to find one last
place where there was water I mean all
of this and then you learn two big
things one that the electric company had
asked for several years for approval to
spend the money getting rid of the
invasive grasses that are at the heart
of the fire and they've been turned down
because the money was supposed to be
spent on going green while they went red
and killed people and second that you
did have an a former Obama official who
was a water resource manager who for
five hours
refused to release the water who wanted
to talk about
how do we make sure that everything's
worked out all right and frankly there's
a movement among some of the left-wing
nutcakes in Ohio and in Oahu and Maui to
not allow water to be used to fight
fires now let me explain that to me they
value the uh the Water going to the
tarot crop more than the water
protecting human beings I just think
that's an extraordinary
psychological condition it's not
ideological it's psychological
you know I I I I always used to say
there's no such thing as a stupid
question but this is a stupid question
and that would be if this was a
republican if this was Donald Trump what
would the reaction be Mr Speaker
well he saw a little George with George
W bush and and Katrina I mean the the
New York Times will be page one all the
major networks would have horrendous
stories every single uh person out there
who serves on you know the NBC CBS would
be condemning this heartless cruel I
mean you have but you have to say to
yourself this is beyond just being
heartless this guy is nuts he's out of
touch with reality I mean how can he
stand in Lahaina surrounded by Death
and talk about your 67 Corvette I mean
it really worries me that this is the
guy who's commander-in-chief for the
most powerful military in the world and
believe me every leader on the planet
watches Joe Biden collapsing and knows
that the U.S is beginning to be
available as a victim because this
commander-in-chief in fact is sort of a
I would say he's closer to being a
sleeper in Chief than he is to being a
commander-in-chief let me ask you about
I don't know again going to get into
this with John Solomon in a minute what
I believe a real bribery money
laundering allegations uh against Joe
Biden we know he lied when it came to
the issue of ever speaking to his son
brother or anybody for that matter a lot
as a candidate light as a president we
see these millions and millions of
dollars in deals from foreign entities
many hostile regimes towards this
country
we find out that the original plan the
New York Times actually broke this story
that the guy investigating for four
years was a friend of Beau Biden many in
his office apparently knew the bidens
and he was ready to deep six all the
charges against Hunter until the IRS
whistleblowers blew the lid off it then
he went to plan B Plan B was oh okay uh
we'll just um uh we'll we'll have a
sweetheart deal and they bury immunity
into the deal and the gun diversion
portion of of this plea deal and then
underneath that the judge looks at it
and says to the prosecutor have you ever
seen a deal like this before no I never
have and now we're discovering too that
well you know the Hunter's lawyers were
saying you do know if this is brought to
trial we're going to ask Joe Biden to
testify he'll be a fact witness in in
all of this
and that you know they would force Joe
to testify and then they wanted Hunter's
lawyers wanted the Biden doj to
prosecute what does this look like to
you Mr Speaker
look I don't think it's complicated uh
first of all Hunter has no capacity to
be grateful no capacity to think Beyond
his own addicted self so he's going to
do whatever he has to do to try to
protect himself but but let's let's be
honest for a minute I mean I'd ask every
American you look at all the information
it's not complicated Joe Biden is a
crook his family are crooked they run
but it's basically it's ironic that
Donald Trump's being charged under Rico
well in fact Joe Biden has been running
an organized crime operation I think if
you watch The Sopranos take out the
murders and watch the rest of The
Sopranos you'll understand the bidens uh
this whole notion that it's really
complicated it's really confusing no
it's not uh barisma a Ukrainian company
in deep trouble is paying a million
dollars a year to Hunter Hunter's father
who's vice president United States picks
up the phone apparently under three
different aliases is using a phone which
some people believe was
Peter Schweitzer among others believe
was probably paid for by one of Hunter
Biden's companies so here City in the
White House is the vice president United
States talking on a secret phone using
an alias talking to the president of
Ukraine on behalf of the company which
is paying his son a million dollars now
how hard is it to understand that
I think virtually any honest opportunity
this is crooked
and Hunter at the time is an admitted
drug addict with no experience in oil
energy gas at all or Ukraine amazing
that you can make that much money and
then you can make money from China and
Russia and Joe said oh I never spoke to
my son but he's meeting with these
oligarchs at the Cafe Milano and calling
into all these business meetings just to
talk about the weather
speaker Gingrich great to see you my
friend thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else